we are indeed with Nazi paikiza after
her first Victory here at the USGS
Championship with Nazi welcome to the
show congratulations it's been a
difficult event for you up to this point
how important was for you to win this
game thank you Christian it's really
good to be here
um yeah I had a really rough start there
were at least two games where I was very
close to winning and in time Scrabble
didn't manage to convert
so it feels
so good to finally win and with black
faces and how did you uh get ready for
this event because we know you haven't
been that active but you always come and
you show or at least try to show your
best here at the U.S championship
yeah so clearly I didn't prep well
enough but in the last two two and a
half months I've been studying chess
just by myself I don't have a coach or
anything
um and I took my time off of everything
else of the all the other projects and
even social media so even social media
cut off every distraction I like that
now take us through uh today's game
right so today she played uh Advanced
Carol and she didn't expect H5 because I
used to play H6 before
um but uh yeah I switched to H5 and
didn't really remember this line to be
honest um
when I checked her game she had played
Bishop D3 and Bishop G5 not C4
but yeah
I think I got a comfortable position and
at least this is a familiar opening to
me I've played it dozens of times so I
felt comfortable and I knew the ideas
uh then she gave me pawn on H4 and I
don't think it was a good sacrifice
because I couldn't see any decent
conversation for her this one on H4 at
this point
uh Bishop to H4 Bishop to E3 did this
move surprised you yeah absolutely I
expected Bishop E7 97 and maybe Rook C1
Rook yes I will Castle short and
it's probably equal maybe slightly
better for white but
yeah I was I was fine with this position
very symmetrical you have some light
coming to F5 it looks pretty decent for
you right
but I'm trying to make this move Bishop
to E3 and just gave you a pawn yeah I
think she didn't want to get kind of
equal position so she wanted to go all
in maybe but I really don't see the
conversation and then she gave me
another Pawn on B4 and after that I was
pretty confident that I was winning
of these before you have two pawns you
cannot Castle on the queen side you
cannot Castle on the king side but you
don't have to exactly my King's fine
only eight only eight very nice uh Nazi
congratulations a big victory for you
and I'm sure we're going to see uh more
brilliant just from you in the upcoming
games I hope so thank you
indeed uh congratulations uh to you